So we're going to generalize this
notion of a Bellman equation to
Bellman Equations.
And the way we're going to do that is by
noting that in the previous derivation.
The way that we're thinking about
things is we capture this V here,
as the repeating structure that's
starts with the max a, right?
So it's actually this piece.
This sort of infinite piece here.
So the whole V consists
of this sub V in it and
this is why this piece gets
substituted for the V in the equation.
>> Yeah, and that makes sense.
And you have an infinite number of
these things going on forever and ever.
And I noticed an infinite
number of left parentheses and
not enough right parentheses.
Oh, no.
This stripe bracket
has traditionally represented
the balancing of all left parentheses.
>> Oh, right.
That's from LISP.
>> Yeah, it's just a shorthand.
>> Nice.
Nice lisp.
LISP.
See?
Lisp.
>> Lisp.
>> [LAUGH] Nice LISP reference.
>> Thanks!
But the thing is because this is
an infinite sequence, there's actually
a number of other ways that we
can group this infinite sequence.
So let me draw another one.
>> Okay.
>> So we can also group
the infinite sequence here.
And notice that it repeats like this.
So, this expression after the max,
the starting from the R and
then moving forward repeats again here.
And so we can actually make
a new equation that depends on
that substructure repeated.
So let me right that out.
So, the idea is, we can actually just
give a name to this big outer brace.
So we'll call it, Q (s,a) and
we'll say it's equal to R (s,a) plus
the discount factor times the sum
over the next possible state, so
the probably of getting there.
Times max a2, our next max, of and then
there's that repeating structure again
so we can just plug in Q of
S prime a prime for that.
This gives us another Bellman equation
that instead of starting at the S point.
Kind of starts after
the action has started.
>> Well, wait if it starts after the
action has started why isn't it Q of a?
>> Okay that's a fair question.
So could we have written
the Q value of an action,
the Q value of this point
in the sequence, this way?
Right, the reward for leaving that
state and taking that action,
plus the discounted value of the future.
What's the problem with this?
>> Well, I see two problems.
One is kind of mathematical and
one is sort of semantic.
So, mathematically,
it doesn't make sense,
because where did the S come from,
in R(S,a)?
>> Yeah,
this is an unbound variable, right?
So that's an error.
>> We can't have that.
And the second is,
when you actually write it that way, so
here you're arguing that Q is like V?
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
So you're asking me what the qual view.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Of a is.
But the value of
an action is meaningless,
except in the presence of the state
where you're taking an action.
>> That's exactly right.
So, in particular,
we're conditioning our reward on
both the state and the action.
So it doesn't really make
sense to be able to talk about
what our future value's going to be if
we don't really know where we started.
So the idea here is that we started
at some state S, we take action a and
then we proceed every after.
>> Okay, so that makes sense.